okay today i'm going to talk to you
about
transformer calculations so there's two
different type
of calculations we need to do when it
comes to transformers
and the nice thing is we don't have to
remember either of them
the equations for each of them on the
equation page
on your p2 paper we could actually
find those equations i'll put a red box
around them this time to show
those equations right there now what
i've done is i've written them out
bigger for the purposes of this video
we're going to look at each one one at a
time
so if we remember the whole purpose of a
transformer
is to change the potential difference
so we're going to take these uh
calculations one at a time
in order to try and figure out how to do
them
so two three four okay
so let's imagine first of all we've got
this transformer here
i could tell this is step up transformer
because it's got more turns on this
on the secondary coil compared to the
primary coil let's just imagine
we've got 10 volts that we start off
with here and we're trying to find out
the number of volts the potential
difference on this side here
after using this transformer so
if we have a look at this we've got two
turns here
on our primary coil and we have one two
three
four on our secondary so first of all
we're going to look
which equation to use now this one
is using voltage in the primary over
voltage of the secondary equals number
of turns at the primary over number
terms of the secondary
this one is using voltage and current
at the primary compared to voltage and
current at the secondary
so because we're dealing with number of
turns we're going to deal with this
equation here
so the first thing i'm going to do
actually
with these transformer equations i
normally find it easier
to put the numbers in first so
substitute first
before rearranging so voltage at the
primary
is 10 divided by voltage at the
secondary
which is what i don't know so i'm going
to keep it as that
equals number of turns at the primary so
there's two turns of the primary
divided by my number of turns on the
secondary
which is now i'm just going to simplify
this a little bit to make it easier so
that's going to be 10
divided by vs equals 2 divided by 4
which is 0.5 so
what i need to do now is i need to
rearrange
this equation to make v s the subject of
the equation
so what i'm going to do first of all is
i'm going to multiply both sides by the
s
and that will give me 10
equals 0.5 times v
s so i now want to get vs all by myself
so i'm now
going to divide both sides by 0.5
so if i divide that side by 0.5 and i
divide that side by 0.5
i now have 10 divided by 0.5
equals v v s
so remember that's the voltage at the
secondary so 10 divided by half
is 20 volts
so all that i've done there is i've
found the equation from the back i've
figured out which one i'm going to use
i've counted the number of turns and
then i've put the numbers into the
equation
and i've rearranged the other type of
equation
that i might have to do is
for um for this one here so in
let's say if i'm not looking at my
number of turns
so i just have this here
now i'm told this time on my
primary coil so let me see one two three
four so let's say this time i'm told
that i've got 10 volts here
and also 10 amps and
at my secondary coil i now have 5 amps
but i don't know my potential difference
so because this time i'm given amps and
volts
i'm going to use this equation here
so my voltage at my primary 10
times my my current at my primary
10 equals my voltage of my secondary
that's what i don't know so i'm going to
leave that as vs
times my current at my secondary
5. so first of all i'm just going to
simplify this
so 100 equals
vs times 5. now again
i want vs all by itself so all i'm going
to do
is divide both sides by 5.
divide that by five divide that by five
so now
i've got 20 equals
vs so my vs my voltage my secondary is
20.
so when i'm doing transformer
calculations all i need to do
pick the right equation depending on
whether i know the number of turns
and the voltage or whether i'm dealing
with the voltage and the current
so then what i need to do is i
substitute the numbers in
and then merely rearrange them in order
to calculate
remember if i've got a step up
transformer my voltage should always
increase if i have a step down
transformer my voltage should always
decrease thank you